the killing of Molly Tibbets is
reigniting calls by some Republicans for
tougher border protection policies
yesterday Christian bikina Rivera a farm
worker living in the US illegally was
charged with Tibbets murder the
University of Iowa student disappeared
on July 18th while out for a jog police
say Rivera confessed and led them to her
body on Tuesday Adriana Diaz is at the
county courthouse in Montezuma Iowa
Adriana good morning good morning Rivera
had his initial appearance here in court
where his charges and his rights were
read to him I was in the courtroom and
you could feel the emotion on both sides
for people there for Rivera and those
there for Tibbets at certain moments
people in the gallery had their head in
their hands in tears wearing handcuffs
and headphones for Spanish translation
24-year old Christian by Hannah Rivera
made his first appearance before a judge
and the public since his arrest for
allegedly killing Molly Tibbets Mr
Rivera you have been charged with murder
in the first degree
Rivera's from Mexico and federal
officials tell CBS News he's
undocumented a person came in from
Mexico illegally and killed her
we need the wall we need our immigration
laws changed
we need a border laws changed President
Trump was part of a growing course of
Republicans yesterday to cite Tibbets
case as a reason for stronger
immigration laws
Rivera's lawyer Allen Richards who in
court papers claims Rivera's here
legally said those comments could hinder
his clients right to a fair trial the
government has weighed in at the highest
levels of a predisposition that this
young man Christian is guilty but in our
system of justice he's entitled to that
presumption of innocence
the owners of yarrabee farms the dairy
farmer Rivera worked for for years say
he was a good employee he got along well
with his co-workers this is this is
shocking Jane Lane who's part of a
well-known Republican political family
here claims Rivera gave them government
IDs with a different name
he also says they used the wrong
government screening system to verify
his employment eligibility
what we learn in the last 24 hours is
that our employ was not who he said he
was given the political debate Mali
tippets aunt wrote on Facebook please
remember evil comes in every color the
family wasn't in the courtroom but they
did release a statement thanking
well-wishers for their support and
prayers the suspect Rivera will be back
in court
August 31st Norah all right Adriana
thank you